so
i think that what we're going to do
is again play a bad opening uh with
either caller and then try to spend some
time recovering from but i'm not going
to blunder a piece i'm just going to
play a bad line
or a bad opening and then i'm going to
try to recover from it maybe a bond
cloud i don't know
that's actually not a bad idea i mean
it's not just a troll it would be a good
way for me to talk about king safety and
how to improve king safety
let's do that seriously let's play a
bomb cloud
but let's play it in a serious way where
we i then try to explain how i recover
from it
in fairness in my defense um disclaimer
i haven't played it before
and i might end up getting crushed but i
don't think i will
[Music]
okay von cloud speedrun here we go
10 minute game 1432.
we're assuming that he plays e4 i mean
no which of course he does and i guess
he'll play a bomb cloud on the other
side d4 d5 and then king d7
okay let's play queen's gamma decline
and then let's play king seven
pretend it's a mouse slip
all right there we go
now
this version of the bomb cloud honestly
is even is not even that bad because the
queen's gambit is not the most
aggressive opening
but nonetheless now we can't castle and
we have a king on e7 so
okay so what's going to be the the first
step to recovery well we don't
necessarily need to bring the king back
to e8 immediately but we will need to do
that at some point the ideal scenario
here is for us to castle by hand
um so let's begin by
by trying to complete our development
knight f6
and at this point i think it's a good
idea to drop the kick back to e8 that's
one approach
um the other approach is to fianchetto
the bishop and then try to castle by
hand go rookie eight bishop f8 the
problem with fianchettoing is that he's
got this move b3
and then the bishop can come out to a3
and prevent us from running the king
back to f8
so we can
rely on the fact that he won't see it
which is one possibility and probably
that's what we're going to end up doing
and king e8 is the other possibility but
let's go g6 if he goes b3 we'll just go
bishop g7 and in response to bishop a3
we'll just drop the king back to e8 okay
so let's be in keto
and we are only two steps away from
castling by hand yes f4 so obviously we
shouldn't go rook f8 because that would
block
the king's passage to f8 we should go
rook e8
and the first step has been completed we
have gotten our king to safety on f8
and i would even
bring the king all the way to g8
oh 15 bucks from lazy thank you
okay now step two of course we've spent
all these tempi
now we need to actually do stuff in the
center and complete our development
so
this entire construction is pretty
flimsy
and we need to somehow break it down
right that construction is flimsy but if
we don't do anything to it
white's going to have total positional
domination over the position
so
what should we do how should we go about
and we had this in the last speed run
we had this particular move in the last
speed run
yeah c5
let's just break down
white center as quickly as we can
because he's getting stuff done on the
king's side we don't have time to waste
let's go c5
yeah but h5 is not dangerous the thing
to understand about h5 is because we
have this construction this is actually
very solid
this is very very solid and there's no
threat h takes g6 we just play h takes
g6
so we should begin by taking on d4
and then the question to you guys is
should we take on c4 is that a good idea
or not
is it is it a good idea to trade one
more time on c4
and again i always catch you guys on
this question i ask a question like this
and because you're used to saying no
because most uh most of the time that
these kinds of questions are asked the
answer is no that's how i get you the
answer is yes
we should absolutely take on c4 well why
should we take on c4 well i mentioned
that it's a good idea to open the center
here if you look at the position after
dc
white is left with an isolated queen
pawn on d4
we are now uh pressuring that pawn with
our queen which is the best of all
worlds
and uh there's just no downside to the
move he takes away that's why we played
c5 we're trying to open up the center
uh in order to by busting open the
center we're going to make it a lot
harder for white
to focus his attention on the king side
if that makes sense for instance the
queen is now tied down to the d4 pawn
okay now we need to continue our
development and in particular
we need to develop the knight on b8 well
where should we go with it there's
actually two approaches we could take
the first approach is to go knight b to
d7
and then knight b6 and knight d5
blockading the square in front of the
iqp
but i would prefer a more direct
approach i think we should try to get
rid of this knight as quickly as
possible
and i think we should just go knight c6
uh the move b6 is bad because of queen
f3 i think
okay 92
92 what should we do now well now we can
for instance we can blockade the pawn
with knight t5
um
but ideally
we would want yeah we do want to
fianchetto this bishop we want to play
b6 and bishop b7 but we can't do that
because the knight is going to hang
so how can we prepare the move b6 you
might ask yourself what do you need to
do
in order to prepare b6 well you need to
do you need to defend this knight
what can you defend it with
well if you defend it with a bishop that
defeats the purpose we're trying to put
the bishop on the long diagonal you can
defend it with a queen
but where should you defend it from well
you should defend it from a square such
that the queen
maintains its pressure on d4
that's why i don't like queen c7
and that's why i like the square queen
d6 no not queen b6 because that blocks
the b-pawn
so by process of elimination we come up
with this move
okay so that's actually
amazingly that he played queen d3
because he is stopping b6 because of
knight takes c6 and bishop b5
so what we should probably do is go
knight b4 and chase that queen away
and then we can play b6
thank you zeus for two now does that
make sense we go knight before
and then we're going to try to play b6
okay this guy is pretty good i have to
say he's
not
folding over and dying
okay so he's contemplating where to put
his queen
do you guys see why b6 doesn't work here
did i explain that properly why does b6
not work because
he trades on c6 and then he has bishop
b5 pinning the queen to the rook
that's why queen d3 is good because the
b5 square was previously unprotected
and that's why we play knight before we
just get the knight away from there so
that we can play okay queen e3 another
excellent move
so again you have to be stubborn with
your ideas
b6 blunders the rook
therefore you play rook b8
and now in addition to b6 you might even
consider going b5 if possible with tempo
attacking the bishop
not just automatically playing b6
yeah knight c2 was possible but taking
this pawn on d4 is is quite dangerous it
opens up the center and with our
position being as cramped as it is
opening up the center completely i think
favors white which is kind of a weird
thing to say it's a good thing for us to
keep this pawn alive if that makes sense
by keeping this fun alive we're keeping
the d file closed
which is not allowing white to really
pressure us in the center
so i'll explain after the game but
knight c2 1964 is not a free pawn
it looks like a free pawn but it gives
white a huge initiative trust me i'll
explain after the game
and this is where you know
your understanding hopefully will be
advanced
okay now as explained
rather than just going b6 passively
let's go b5 and do the same thing with
the gain of tempo
should be seven
and now we got all our pieces out which
is great we still have this pesky knight
on e5 to deal with but that's okay we
can work around it that night's not the
end of the world
at night's honestly not the end of the
world
if he ever goes a3 we can drop our
knight back to d5 we have an excellent
blockading square
in front of the isolated queen pawn
which i've explained many many times
this is the ideal square
okay
so we should just continue making active
moves here
there's no like
way to play this type of position
right you just look at your pieces you
see what can be improved
so for instance i look at this knight on
f6
and i see that it can jump out to e4
well that looks like a pretty active
move right 94 looks like a looks like a
good way to improve our position so
these positions don't overthink them
a5 a4 is another excellent idea here by
the way try to get this bishop off of b3
rook
well not rookie c8 i would play rook bc8
i actually think this rook 98 is pretty
valuable it's protecting the e6 pawn
so it's it's really discouraging knight
takes f7 shenanigans so play reasonably
and don't
you know always think that there's
there's some algorithm to finding the
best move sometimes it's just like okay
i'm going to look around the board and
i'm going to improve the position of my
pieces that's it
that's really it
his position is good he's played very
very well so far okay queen g4
let's continue improving the position of
our pieces
well now i'm looking at the knight on b4
i think the time has come for us you
know one thing i see about the move
queen g4 is that it
it does uh cause the bishop to be
undefended
which means that what move now is a
little bit more enticing than it
previously was well that's the move
knight back to d5 because it actually
hits the bishop
does that make sense
okay good
i'm a little bit worried about the move
rook f3 that that would be a very good
move
okay he takes it what should we take
back with
yeah we should take back with the queen
to prepare the battery absolutely let's
prepare the battery now you might look
at this and say well wait a minute i
don't get it
what are you talking about isn't the
queen defending g2 but this is what
chess is all about
you're playing the short-term game but
you're also playing the long-term game
what if the queen
leaves g4 at some point what if he goes
queen h4 you never know how the
circumstances might change
and so
you know there's no downside to taking
with the queen you're just building up a
battery for the future
and you might also go a move you might
also play a move like knight f6
okay it goes to rook f3
now we should continue improving our
position
now we should continue improving our
position now knight f6 is possible but i
don't really see the point of it because
we're not attacking the rook
what can we do to improve our position
look around which pieces can be improved
which pieces can be activated absolutely
we can play rook bc8 and try to
infiltrate c2 with our rook
now am i worried about the rook lift no
because here's the thing even if the
queen appears on h7 after king f8
white's gonna have a hard time finding a
follow-up
that's a good thing i call the best and
worst-case scenario test like if your
opponent has an idea and you think that
idea is scary and you're not sure ask
yourself what happens if i let my
opponent
fully accomplish his idea his or her
idea
and you do that you say okay well what
if i goes queen h4 and then queen h7
check well how scary is that in reality
it's not you just go king f8 oh my
headphones died
okay so
now we can continue activating with rook
c2
and at this point what i want you to
notice is that the queen is overloaded
what is black threatening in this
position
what is black threatening in this
position
look carefully
knight f6 knight f6 is right
why is knight f6 the threat because the
queen is overloaded it's guarding g2 and
it's guarding the knight
and it can't do both at the same time if
you play knight f6 so knight f6 queen f3
you will take the queen and then the
knight on e2 will be hanging
knight takes g6 okay this looks like
desperation to me
um
now let's be accurate
don't automatically grab the knight on
g6 if you grab the knight he takes queen
takes g6 you can kind of see what he's
trying to do
we have a much better move than f takes
g6
what move is that
yeah we can play knight f6
we can still play knight f6 there's no
reason not to
this is a paper tiger it looks dangerous
but in reality it doesn't actually
produce anything there's no threat
associated with that knight once we take
the knight on e2 we will be threatening
to take on g2
with absolutely devastating effect
in fact rook him bishop takes h8
and if 97 check there's king f8 i did
see that
good catch but it doesn't work
yeah rook had checked is a common
pattern if we had a rook on f8 well i
guess then 97 would be checkmate but
rookie chait check has to be considered
roke chain has to be considered but
then we play bishop takes h8
if the knight moves anywhere but e7 then
we will be able to take the queen
and after 97 check we just move the king
to f8
and then if he takes his our queen then
we take his queen with our knight
that line makes sense
i hope you can
follow that line in your mind
rocket shade bishop h8
97 king f8
and then he can take our queen but then
we will take his queen
just and and don't be afraid of trying
to visualize like everybody can try to
visualize lines and that helps you with
calculation
like as i'm saying these lines really
try to make those moves in your mind
but it doesn't matter i'm up remember
that i i'm essentially up a piece
already and i will i'm sorry i will be
up a piece
once the next move happens and rocket
check gives up a rook so i don't really
care about pawns at the end of the line
yeah he might flag i mean white's
position is lost he starts to lose all
of his pieces here
okay
this is collapse knight c3 now it's easy
to get overwhelmed in a position like
this but
you should break this down into its
component pieces so one option is to
take the queen
and then once he takes our queen we can
just take the knight and we'll be up a
piece
but there is a much better move here
yeah the better move is rook takes g2
check that that was ultimately our idea
if queen takes 32 then this is mate okay
and if he had gone king f1
well what's the fastest win well as i
always talk about when there's two
queens and they're hanging the first
thing you should look at is whether you
can move your queen away with check
can you move your queen away with check
you can queen c4 check that actually
wins the queen
after queen e2 you can take the queen
a simple game
um it's
i mean i don't feel like i really spend
a lot of time in recovery
so because really what we did and you
know i played very straightforwardly we
just castled by hand
and i got a little bit fortunate i think
even here the move b3 would be very
nasty because the bishop comes out to a3
and if you go rookie 8 you actually just
lose your queen
so you're
you know you're not in time and here we
would have probably gone like knight bd7
bishop a3 and then walked back to e8
so
once we got our king
to
f8 and then g8 okay we have a position
down a bunch of tempi but it's still
fine
and notice what we did here we go c5
immediately just contesting his center
then we trade everything and we go
knight c6 we pound at the center
and around here i think white is still
doing well here he should have gone
bishop e390 to is passive
queen d3 is a very nice move
rook b8 bishop e3 b5 now already at this
point i think white is worse
but here he started going really wrong i
think
maybe even the move f5 can be considered
with white here
and um white has some sort of
attack i guess
yeah this looks interesting well f5 if
you play e takes f5 you give up f7
how would white prevent manual casting
well that's that's what i indicated with
b3 the way to prevent manual castling in
this specific position is
is really even here to play the move b3
and then develop hyper fiance of the
bishop to a3 and do you see that that
prevents the king from walking over to
f8 and g8
in every position there is its own way
to deal with like a bomb cloud type
structure so if you consider a
traditional bomb cloud
here it's like you don't even need to
work as hard to get to the king like one
of the best ways to play against the
traditional bog cloud is of course to
just rip open the center asap
and the real battle revolves around
weatherwise able to castle my hand
if that makes sense
yeah so that was a decent game we'll do
more of this and you know i think it'll
be more interesting when we get to like
18 1900 and i do something like this
that'll be you know really there will be
a lot of meat on the bone there because
you know these players are gonna
actually be very good at punishing me
so you have a lot to look forward to i'm
gonna do some interesting stuff as we
ascend further down the road in our
third speed run if you guys have been
enjoying it i hope it's not getting
too repetitive
every speed when i finish i say it's
going to be the last and then i start
another one but
um so far it's been it's been going well
so i'm going to keep this going as long
as people find it beneficial i feel like
there's always going to be new stuff to
talk about it's not like i'm going to
exhaust
topics and yeah thanks everybody for
for the support thank you for all the
messages of improvement it
really um
it really means a lot when i see the
impact that this has
truly
i'll see you guys later thank you so
much
bye everybody
[Music]